ما يسمى ب
الحرب لن يكون لها صورة النصر لأن
الصورة عبارة عن صورة خسارة 1300 قتيل
وتم إعادة 240 مختطفاً منهم
التي تم إرجاعها وبوكا وبولكا
200.000 لاجئ في بلادهم صورة انتصاري
كن عندما يخرج رئيس الوزراء هذا
هذه هي صورة النصر لا شك فيها، وهذا ما نحن من أجله
نحن بحاجة إلى استهداف هذا الجمهور بأكمله وأكثر من ذلك
الملايين في دولة إسرائيل للحصول على الصورة
هذا النصر خسرنا فيه الكثير
العمى الذي كنا نرقد فيه حتى اليوم إذا
يمكنك القول أن العمى قد أصبح خلفنا بالفعل
ترى الواقع بكل وضوح كل شيء
شفافة وواضحة لم نعد نؤمن بها
الدفاعات الخاملة التي آمنا بها في الماضي واليوم أريدها
إن قول شيء بسيط للغاية هو في بعض الأحيان الطريق إلى الأمام
وينبغي أيضا أن تتضمن بعض الخطوات إلى الوراء ويمكن
سواء كان ذلك هو الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب القيام به لإعادة التنظيم
وفكر أولاً في مدى أهمية الأشياء الأساسية للعدو
العدو يسمع، العدو يستمع، العدو يشاهد، العدو يتعلم
كل ما يتعلمه تيرون في اليوم الذي يهضمه بالضبط
استمتعنا ببعض بيروت وبأنوفنا هناك
الجميع يقول الجيش هو أقوى دولة في البلاد
ليس هناك لست هناك تعلمت درسا في التواضع
درس في التواضع يعني أنك تعيش هنا في الغابة
هذا، وإذا كنت تعتقد أنك قوي، ميشا سوف يركع
لا تذهب إذا كنت تعتقد أنك رجل ذكي
سيخبرك أنك غبي وتعتقد أنك عشي
شخص تكنولوجي وذكي بأكثر الطرق بدائية
وسيأتي القرف ويثبت السلام كما ذكرنا في السابعة
في أكتوبر ولهذا السبب أقول أن هناك مشاكل هنا
الاستراتيجيات التي تحتاج إلى تسويتها ولكن الآن
يوجد الآن شيء واحد هو الأكثر أهمية في عالم مستخدمي الإنترنت
صحيح، لكننا مستعدون لدفع الأسعار التي أثبتناها
وفي الماضي أيضاً أوقفنا القتال ولكن من
ومن يسمع آيلاند يخاف أن نضيع لا سمح الله
ولن نعيد المختطفين لأننا
رسائل لتلقي صفقة تتضمن نهاية القتال
ولن ننهار حماس لأننا غير مستعدين
انتقل إلى التحركات الحاسمة من دومير هار مادشال الآن
من الواضح إذا كنت تعتقد أننا لن نحصل عليه
هذا العدو في يوم من الأيام
بعد لست متأكدا أعتقد أولا وقبل كل شيء ثانيا
ويلتزم الدائنون المتشابكون بالتحديد
للقيادة الإسرائيلية إذا تم تحديد القيادة
كونك قويًا غير مصمم بما فيه الكفاية، سأتصل
ووفقا لرئيس الأركان، فإنني منزعج من كلماته
اليوم يعملون بطريقة محدودة للغاية في مواقف السيارات
وفي رفح لم نلمس طريق فيلادلفيا على الإطلاق
رفح ليست تحت السيطرة الإسرائيلية وقد بدأوا بالفعل في المحادثات
التقارب مرة أخرى على الخط الحدودي هو كلام
وهو في رأيي سابق لأوانه واعتقدت أننا كذلك
قريب جدًا جدًا من أسرة حماس، كما قيل لنا
الآن يقول المعلق العسكري: لا، سوف يستغرق الأمر
[موسيقى]
تو ثلاثة رقم جديد م
ب
لهذا السبب فهي ليست فكرة جيدة
في نوفمبر، في 1 نوفمبر، قام بدفع الكثير إلى السجادة
الزي العسكري للهمص أ يستخدم للتدمير
سيتم تدميرها
[موسيقى]
الساخنة
إذا كنت الفائز، فإن استمرار المحاكمة سيكون في الشمال
الحزام حسنًا، لا أعرف ولكن لنفترض الأم
لقد دمرنا حماس في شمال القطاع الذي نحن فيه
في مكان مختلف تمامًا عما كنا فيه في السادس عشر
في نوفمبر وتقول ذلك من أجله إذا كنت تعلم
أين يقع السنوار بالضبط أو تقريبًا هو أمر مهم
سأخبرك أن ما أقدره هو رئيس الوزراء
وقال إنني أقدر أنه سيكون من الممكن الوصول إليه
لا أعرف كيفية تعريفه بينما أدرك أنه ليس كذلك
هرب من الشريط، وبالتالي إذا كنت تتصرف بشكل صحيح وحكيم
يمكنك الوصول إليه وحقا النقطة التي أنا فيها
أعتقد أن الجيش فوجئ بقصة النطاق
النفق هو الشيء الذي فاجأني لأنني لا أعتقد ذلك
رفع إشارات دائرة النفق كما هي ويسمح بذلك
بعض الناشطين نجوا، وهذا هو بيت القصيد
محاكمة قبل اسبوعين يقول رئيس الوزراء
نحن
لقد اقترب الأمر، إنها بداية نهاية الخامس، فأين؟
نحن صغار نعم أنا أتحدث عن الجنود
الذين هم في الميدان حول العائلات التي تخشى التعرض للطرد
لهم عند الباب